[music]
>> This is number two.
Number three
is
that you have to become a misali.
You have to become an example to the
other people.
If your actions do not match your words,
then the enemies of Islam will have
something to tell about the message of
Islam.
They will get an opportunity to blame
Islam just because your actions are not
matching your words.
So, as
a day of Allah, it is very very
important
that you practice your faith first.
You implement your Islam on yourself
first.
If
I do not offer my salah
and I do not wake up for my Fajr prayer
and I'm giving a talk on the importance
of salah,
I'm making a fool of myself.
And a strict warning has been given by
Rasulullah alaihi wasallam with regards
to this. It's a Hadith of Sahih
al-Bukhari. Rasul alaihi wasallam said
that on the day of judgement
when the people of hell will enter the
hellfire,
they will see a man carrying his
abdominal contents in his own hands
and running around in hellfire
like a donkey runs around the mill.
He's running. He's panicked.
He's crying and running with his
abdominal contents in his hands. So, the
people of Jahannam see this man and they
say, "Oh, this is the man who used to
call me towards good, forbid me from
evil. How come he's in the hellfire?"
So, they go and inquire with him.
Okay, why? What happened?
So, this man will say,
"Yes, my people.
I invited you towards good.
I used to enjoin what is good, forbid
what is evil,
but I practiced it not myself. May Allah
save us from such shame.
Save us from such results which would
lead a day of Allah, a one
who called the people towards Allah to
be landed into Jahannam and face such a
severe torment only because he was not a
misali.
All the prophets of Allah, they were the
best exemplary, including the last and
the final messenger Rasulullah
alaihi wasallam. Allah
mentions in Surat al-Ahzab, chapter 33,
verse number 21. Allah says,
Verily, in the messenger of Allah, you
have the best example to follow.
They were the best examples.
If you notice the seal of the Prophet
alaihi wasallam
before he attained the prophethood,
yet he was very well known for his
honesty, for his truthfulness, for his
trustworthiness.
People believed in him.
And that is precisely why when he came
with the message of Allah, he asked the
people standing on Mount Safa, "Oh, my
people,
have I ever told you a lie?"
People said, "No, never. We have never
found you telling a lie. Have I ever
betrayed anyone?" They said, "We never
found you betraying anyone. You're
rather al-Amin. You're a Sadiq. You're
the truthful. You're the trustworthy."
He had won them over by his character.
Many of the people of Mecca accepted
Islam only because of the character of
the Prophet
alaihi wasallam.
The way how he dealt with the people,
the way how he maintained his relations
with his neighbors, with his relatives,
with his tribe, with the people coming
from out, all this made a big
difference.
So, it's very important for a day of
Allah
to practice what he preaches.
Again, let me clarify a misconception.
There are certain groups of Muslims who
say, "Oh, if you do not practice it,
then you cannot preach at all." You
know, this is going to one extreme.
This is going to one extreme.
What we understand from the Quran and
the Sunnah, if you see it overall, is
that though there are severe warnings,
but that shouldn't prevent a person from
conveying the message of Allah. Rather,
it should become an inspiration for him
to start practicing.
If he's preaching the message of Allah,
then he's required to implement it first
on himself. That should inspire him.
That should motivate him.
But that shouldn't become an excuse.
Okay, for example, I'm not praying my
Tahajjud prayer, so I cannot ask anyone
to pray the Tahajjud prayer.
Rather, that should motivate him.
This is number three.
Number four
is
Allah
mentions in Surat al-Nahl, chapter 16,
verse 125. The verse that which I
recited in the beginning of my talk.
Allah says, "Invite
the people
Invite the people towards the way of the
Lord with hikmah, with wisdom.
And with good preaching. Argue
with them, reason with them, debate with
them in the ways that are best and most
gracious."
This verse of the glorious Quran tells a
day of Allah whenever he starts doing
dawa or whenever he takes up dawa, then
he has to do dawa with hikmah,
with wisdom.
And the commentators of the Quran
when they do the commentary of this
verse of Surat al-Nahl, chapter number
16, verse number 125, they say the
hikmah here means the Sunnah of the
Prophet
alaihi wasallam.
The hikmah here means the Sunnah of the
Prophet.
So, whatever circumstances you may face,
whichever place you may be in,
the thumb rule is you have to follow the
Sunnah of the Prophet
alaihi wasallam in your dawa.
How he behaved with those who were
ignorant,
how he behaved with those who were the
staunchest enemies of him. And we heard
that example earlier by Dr. Zakir Naik
that he prayed for his enemies as well.
How many of us do that?
And I remember
Dr. Zakir Naik in one of his speeches,
he tells in the question and answer
session
or during the lecture
when he made a mention about the
atrocities being done on the Muslim
nations, so a person in the audience
stood up and he said, "Death to George
Bush."
"Death to George Bush."
So, the entire impression of the
program,
the lecture which he delivered for the
people,
all went down in just one person
standing up and saying, "Death to George
Bush."
Then
he replied back and he said, "Rather, we
should make dua to Allah
that he guides George Bush to Islam."
That is the Sunnah of the Prophet
alaihi wasallam. He prayed to Allah to
guide Abu Jahl or Umar
who
were then the staunchest enemies of
Islam.
So, pray to Allah that
the staunchest enemies of Islam
come closer to Islam.
They become a part of the Muslim nation.
There was once a discussion amongst the
duat.
And this is a real incident.
In this discussion,
one of the days
of
one of the cities in India,
he said that it will take hundreds of
years for Muslims to establish the dawa
the way as the Christian missionaries
do. It will take hundreds of years. We
have lost hope.
So, one of the days there,
he knew, he understood, he knew that
hikmah. He said, "Brother, why do you
think negative?
Rather, pray to Allah that these
non-Muslims
who are conveying the message of their
false religion with hikmah, let them
become Muslims. Inshallah. So, they
become a part of us.
So, we don't have to defeat them.
Rather, we should win them over."
So, this is a very important quality
which as a day of Allah, you have to
have every time you call the people
towards Allah. That is wisdom. That is
hikmah.
Number five
is patience.
Sabr.
Allah
says in Surat al-Asr, chapter number
103, verses 1 to 3.
Wal asr.
By the token of time. in in sun of the
hustle.
The entire human kind is in loss.
In the Medina Avenue, except those who
believe while I mean it's all you had
and do righteous deeds. What a lot so
build hack and call the people towards
hack what a lot so the suburb and they
call each other to patience and
perseverance.
Every time you embark on this noble duty
of the hour, you have to know that there
will be obstacles.
You have to know there will be
difficulties.
And the best of human kind, the prophets
of Allah, they were the most tested.
They were the most persecuted, but yet
they did not give up on the call to
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
He preached his people for 950
years.
Today
the days
they talk to a person and suppose he
mocks him or he abuses him, then they
lose hope and they try to avoid that
person.
Is this the attitude that which as they
we have to develop?
No one is allowed to come was mocked at
when Allah instructed him to build an
ark in a desert. People mocked at him.
They laughed at him. They said where are
you going to you know take this ship
sail this ship which you are making?
But did he give up on his call?
He continued to follow the instructions
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So as the
days of Allah, you will be mocked at.
You will be persecuted. You will be
tested. You will face difficulties, but
that does not mean you give up on
patience and perseverance.
One of the most wonderful examples for
this
is the incident of Ta'if which you all
must be aware of or majority of you must
be aware of.
In the incident of Ta'if, when
Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam
lost hope from the people of Mecca that
after continuous preaching, let me try
to the other city. When he went there
he was beaten by the small children of
the street.
Stones were thrown at him. He was
bleeding from head to toe.
And when Hazrat Aisha may Allah be
pleased with her, she asked Rasul
sallallahu alaihi wasallam which was the
most difficult day upon you in your
lifetime.
Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam
made a mention of Ta'if.
That was the most severe day in the life
of Rasul sallallahu alaihi wasallam
where he really felt the pain.
What was the case?
When the angel saw that Rasul sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is being treated in such
a way, the angel of mountain comes to
Rasul sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
says, "Oh Rasulullah,
if you want we'll crush the people of
Ta'if between the two mountains."
So what did Rasul sallallahu alaihi
wasallam say? He did not say, "Yes,
please go ahead."
No.
Rather he bore with patience,
with perseverance.
And he said
"No, rather I hope, I pray to Allah that
the progeny, that the children of this
people of the city, of this city's
people, they become Muslims. They enter
into the fold of Islam."
This is how a day of Allah should be.
Patience and perseverance.
>> [snorts]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.